the new surge of covet cases across the
country is forcing many americans to
rethink their travel plans airports are
busy right now as we get close to
christmas but covet is not the only
concern for airlines there's a
technological and bureaucratic conflict
that could force many of them to cancel
flights in the new year leaving
passengers stranded chris van cleeve is
at washington's reagan national airport
chris this doesn't sound good good
morning to you
well good morning we know based on tsa
numbers about twice as many people are
traveling this year than last year
airlines are starting to see a modest
uptick in people canceling their flights
but really we hear they're watching
today very closely just as they're
starting to sound the alarm about the
potential next round of flight
disruptions and it has nothing to do
with covid and everything to do with
ultra fast 5g cell phone service
a standoff between two federal agencies
could have flight halting consequences
for airlines caught in the middle
starting january 5th u.s airlines may
have to stop using equipment that helps
pilots land in bad weather or low
visibility at more than 40 of the
nation's busiest airports following an
faa order prompted by concerns about
possible interference from newly
activated 5g cell phone towers 5g is now
the biggest issue facing the airline
which is remarkable to say in a world
where we're still uncovered united ceo
scott kirby says airlines have no choice
but to adhere to the faa order we need
the faa and the fcc to sit in a room to
delay this until they sit in a room and
find out a way to do this without
impacting aviation and aviation
customers if we go back to decades-old
procedures and technology for flying
airplanes cancel thousands of flights
per day and hundreds of thousands of
customers it will be a catastrophic
failure of government top executives
from the nation's biggest carriers
expressed concerns during a recent
senate hearing the faa is uncomfortable
with the safety risk and as a
consequence
the impact on our operations to mitigate
that
would be a significant setback former
737 pilot and national transportation
safety board chair robert sumwalt says
planes are safer with those radio
altimeters working
the spectrum band that the radio
altimeters use is very close to the
spectrum band for 5g and that's the
concern is that there's the potential
for spurious signals
from the 5g to
interfere with the radioaltimeter
spectrum the wireless industry insists
there is not a safety issue arguing the
aviation industry's fear-mongering
relies on completely discredited
information and deliberate distortions
of fact a-t-t and verizon are pledging
to reduce signal strength on cell towers
near airports
we have 39 countries where you have this
deployment there have been no
issues tennessee senator marcia
blackburn believes expanded 5g service
is essential what we are looking at is a
late onto the table
objection by the faa were folks just not
talking to each other sometimes we
wonder if they are in
as close communication as they ought to
be in order to get this done in a
statement the faa says it believes the
expansion of 5g in aviation will safely
coexist adding it is working closely
with the federal communications
commission and wireless companies
the fcc tells cbs news it is optimistic
that a solution can be worked out the
wireless companies have spent about 80
billion dollars acquiring this bandwidth
to roll out 5g they oppose any kind of a
delay and the airlines say without a
solution they could have to almost
immediately start canceling or delaying
about a thousand flights a day over the
course of a year it would work out to 32
million flyers being impacted nate
chris thank you so much so many
questions that i had seems like they're
on opposite ends of the spectrum no
unintended but someone isn't telling the
truth well i just think scott kirby of
united airlines pulled no punches
why would the airline want to fear
monger that doesn't make any sense at
all i hope we don't have to pull up that
interview guys
at any time to say look he tried to warn
us back then so did mr kelly from
southwest yeah right now this is very
very frightening they got to work it out
for sure yeah no doubt about it before
we get on that plane yeah yes yeah
you're right about that girl